remaining
[Applause]
science enjoys for the fete violence to
us back out Dillon Brooks caps off his
terrific night
27 points for Brooks season eyes at 31
at 22 and a half
[Applause]
have to be separated more shrub somebody
as well now when she was getting it away
I think objected to the game being
[Applause]
they're going for the steal Lucy tell
jenkins telling these guys to go to the
bench
baton has to be held back
the next security get job holding back
like milk I found out
if the frustration is boiled over here
for the Knicks
Dotson he's upset he doesn't appear any
some either team left the bench which is
always a concern because that's about
the neck suspension which he mentioned
Randall
some people he wasn't there so some
there would be some fines handed out
especially if somebody comes in and
accelerates the altercation and that's
usually means a suspension kudos to the
security for those guys were there they
clash no question they pounced
and I think what happen have to see the
replay again
whoa see that's that's a flagrant foul
and I think what paint was upset with
was that here the games it's an 18-point
game is 48 seconds to go and you're
stealing a ball in the inbounds
Taylor Jenkins trying to tell Randall to
calm down
the one thing you have to be careful of
in all these
Randall is furious is you shouldn't if
if you're a coach on another team when
you start trying to push back players on
the other team all right so here's
here's the play that started it game is
over and Crowder does that so you know
that's one of those unwritten rules that
players get upset with
and that's what cake was upset with as
if the city would have liked you play in
the game man right he had a fetish
Benoit there's two there's two Grizzlies
that left the bench if you don't want
this to happen play ball right exactly I
couldn't agree I'm just saying that's
that's what Payton objected to it's kind
of an old-fashioned unwritten rule but
you know what inbound the ball right way
and catch it
late showing his frustration in his
annex I'm gonna lose back-to-back nights
so the officials are looking at to see
who's going to be ejected my guess is
Payton will be ejected and there might
be one or two others who kind of came in
the middle or came after had started
that's a flagrant - so he'll be he'll be
ejected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]